go
again uh do the same one
again and again nope I do it
again
okay you're going to do it again and I
don't you don't need to change anything
B you just do you I want you to pay
attention to her left elbow plot it in
space and you
go okay did you do you see how it's
you're going to keep doing that when you
tell me what's happening to that left
elbow as you ploted in
space describe what's happening moves
slightly there then stay still here
until say speak up it moves slightly at
the beginning and then stays still
through the rest of the technique all
right let's find out
stop I'm going to plot it in space right
there you do the throw looks like it
went towards the east yes okay so you
weren't accurate so you're going to do
it
again watch the elbow do you see yes
okay we'll have you you guys go that n
get
Taylor let's again moving away from me
and you're going to plot his elbow in
space
nope you're always going to go north
you're always going to throw North
you're you're plotting his
[Music]
elbow what what do you what do you
notice as you plotted in
space anything what do you
notice
what is it staying still or is it moving
in space it's moving it's moving pay
attention it's it's moving Eastward
again watch watch prior to the throat
you see it's going Eastward again okay
uh we'll come back we'll do the other p
and you're going to do the same thing
you don't have to change
anything and uh we're going to now plot
for the hand in Space the wrist
scrab what do you
notice up
down
R pay attention what the same direction
as the it's going in the same direction
so if we plot look at the distance the
wrist is currently from her torso do you
understand now watch as he
throws it got closer to our torso do you
see that and that's a product of that
elbow hinging that's why the wrist gets
closer do you understand okay so we're
going to come and we'll switch the the
other team watch that and again you see
how the Hat the wrist gets closer you
see which is telling you the elbow is
hinging got
it
okay so and you don't have to worry push
push push okay I don't want to stay here
or do do any kind of
segmentation to get things to go see you
see the
segmentation right right at
contact you have
it see this isn't getting closer this is
stay there you can use me for balance
here relax this is not
hinging you see
that uh so right at contact everything
stays the same so even this little
shoulder you see don't no no shoulder
hinge so you want to do the movement
though okay same thing I'm going to come
up but I'm not going to let these hinges
work
up she she's go she's trying to go in
but I'm not going to let
her do you see
that
if we pay attention to the
ukes the ukes disconnect all the time
all the time okay um so if you pay
attention to when so she pushes she's
now not disconnected but when does she
when does she want that right there let
stay there right here is where she'll
take her Center out of the technique and
so the
internal uh energetic manipulation she's
trying to Des segmented she's trying to
disconnect it you see and then the
hinges will become viable again so this
kind of UK gives you a great
opportunity to do you see there it is
again
so once once I have her here I have her
Center so you can see you can move her
any any anywhere you want but once she
goes off balance she's now changing the
angle and disconnecting the center what
you have to do as you advance is not go
back to a hinge she change the vector so
you just keep the energy
instead got it so I don't want to do the
Keyon at the cost of bringing her joints
back in
I just I have the energy the energy is
what I
use every time she
disconnects I keep that lock on her
joints so here that see how she goes
back okay what what she supp us to do
push push okay but she goes back go back
and same thing I can't keep going where
she
disconnected she goes back and I keep
the same thing do you feel you see and
the joints don't
hinge got it okay
Chris so this I don't want
that
see it's just the feeling of
them when does it happen
right when he's about to fall okay so
maybe I take the Keyon up to that part
he starts to pull out and hinge do you
see now to continue on this now here's
where you can push down on that hand you
see he'll he he's giv back leverage to
himself which is what a resisting person
will do they will do that and that's why
they this kind of UK it's not the best
for you n development but for my nogget
development it'll help me train so when
I feel that you see how I felt it goes y
you see how I put it back
on so we'll do that one again just so I
can talk it through as I feel him pull
that do you see rather than push here
and give him the mechanical advantage
there right I brought this this way this
is going this way see and what you
notice is that the hinge stops
working every
time there's that little
hinge there it is
again there's that hinge you see trying
to take energy off it kind of go
down do do you understand so pay
attention to this
segmentation and as
UK because you're
training from the yide of the Yang side
throwing architecture throwing
architecture you want to make yourself
throwable and save the counters for
geisa Okay
so
as I do the prescribe do you
see I have established by Prescription
Center to Center relationship you feel
that okay so if if the camera doesn't
feel what you feel but you see if I
continue to do it you see how I did the
same thing I have her joints not working
so okay so when you I Lish that Center
and you start to go and then I came off
do you see I keep the same
Center okay now here's the interesting
part you might be be very interested in
not training in a drill where my
response is prescribed you might go
that's a bunch of I would
rather learn how to do something when
people counter okay again again save
that for Gaza but if I maintain
Center you're going to see you're never
going to throw me because you segment
okay so I become a much harder UK making
you fail more not succeed more than the
UK who disengages okay so I'll do the
disengagement UK and you go ahead and
throw
me
I want you to be able to describe what
you're
feeling what do you feel um Lou the
weight is getting taken off right as
you're going um off balance a little bit
Topsy tury not really but yes okay so I
keep that description of mine and now I
I get into your
Center so every little
manipulation starts where where it
leaked out before as
UK now takes away from your
throwing uh Force because it's leaking
out there too you see so as you move
from here where I establish Center to
Center As you move from here go ahead
and move
see you're going to do the technique
okay I'm just feel filling all of that
leakage there it is again you see so
imagine you're a you're a Naga and
Sensei says you get four
tries and then your partner gets four
tries so we Bound in and we go
one
two
three oh my
turn
I'm really getting eight tries I see
right okay so again change your
mindset
um don't
prioritize throwing them it's how you
throw them and equally it's how you
fulfill your role as Su okay do you
understand that
so I don't it's not very high
chill lay down on your shoulder
no you don't need that elbow just put
your shoulder on the ground there you go
and did you see how you use your elb
okay just go that's
it now this is very
mushy I'm going to
push good now lower your shoulder
without that getting
mushy yes you see how different that
looked do it
again
yes good do you see her body is
different can you see it or is not
visible you look like you're down it's
visible can you see it okay can you feel
it okay do your segmented shoulder
shoulder you're going to put your
shoulder down that's that's a fear
response this is too high for your mind
so you go a little at a time now now
I'll now I'll risk it okay and now be
segmented different body okay so what
you want to do is not be afraid because
fear segments the body you
locked locked no
again you you have to use your mind I
can't be pushing on this all the time
you use the
M
no do you see
H pressu
eyes no it happens right at the fear
response of falling
okay
so if you if that's the
case then doing the prescribed Uki which
is the role of buuk Not the Falling
okay I get to reconcile fear I'm brought
to the fear crisis the fork in the road
which will you do will you go
unconscious you see will you segment go
unconscious or will you maintain
awareness and in the face of that
gravitation that
egocentrism it's it's a choice okay and
as you as
UK make
yourself be that do that you get eight
reps per every four not four reps
okay pay attention to those joints both
from UK and if they do do it from net
get them back out of play okay
good okay so now pay attention to the
functioning the
articulating the articulation in her
joints have the wrist elbow and the
shoulder what do you
notice there seems to be a little
um we're going back
ands anyone else notice anything there's
energy leakage yes there's energy
leakage which which who could who could
Define what is not being impacted as a
result of that energy leakage CER the
center the center is not being affected
so the center is being sequentially
externally affected so as you work
through each
joint then eventually you're pulling on
the center do do you understand that
okay so the same thing is
here okay so uh when I'm here you see
I'm in the center it's it's in your
Center that's why when you try to
disconnect what do you feel this hand is
doing uh where is it it's in C yeah do
you see okay as opposed to you go ahead
disconnect and I disconnect too okay as
you get and then inversely it's the same
thing here right so as you as I go into
your joints cuz you disconnected go
ahead and do your thing you see like
that now the joints become functional
again but if I if you get to that point
and you disconnect you see and I'm still
in the the center but from a different
vector and you have to be able to do it
on the Fly and the joints stop
functioning every time the joints
function you're going to lose connection
to the center okay
so if you if you watch her Center and we
just plotted in space is it moving is it
is it is it moving through the sagittal
plane that's on the map or is it
rotating are the distal ends of her body
rotating around her Center okay such
that it's because the center is
spinning okay like a imagine a a balar
and I'm spinning it okay or I'm actually
doing some combination of both and
they're spiraling through space like a
corpse through roller coaster so if we
plot her body in space you see uh and I
do this technique here I'm just going
around each joint do you see
that till it goes
down again what does the UK usually
do reconciles the absence of a
mechanical advant a disad absence of a
mechanical advantage okay so she'll go
[Music]
down but because I have my
Center do you
see go
ahead and if I had my inter go ahead if
I had my internal skills to it she's not
going to get me
okay what I want to do is establish
kazushi you
see so that her ability to resist is
less doable because you're mechanically
being disorganized okay so as opposed to
you
pushing and I get out of the way she's
Perfect Balance do you
see so I'm not getting out of the way
you going to have to travel as we move
camera as I get out of the way there's
perfect balance until she reconciles the
energy if she was stronger or until each
joint starts working up its way to the
fector center
okay so instead I'm going to immediately
this same same feeling that I have there
I do want to
yield okay I don't don't just get out of
the way and disconnect the grip from her
Center same same feeling there I keep
that
feeling you see so let's look as I take
get out of her Center watch her steps
watch your
steps what did she do last
time she took that little stutter right
so same feeling there that on there I
keep you see okay now wait go stay there
where you were watch me go off you see
I'm off stand back
up okay go back where you were okay and
same thing do you feel it it's in am I
in the lock no I'm not here's the
lock get back up go back where you were
you felt something though right but it's
not the lock got it do you see try to
stand up
oh a little harder Right add the
[Music]
movement so from here I have it from
here I had it in your Center have
it same projection right going
around come
back
here look at her
joints Flex them in and out
you see usable boom you feel the
difference not not usable so here I
don't go around this I keep this
relationship that same
relationship what do you do as a result
of that relationship pay
attention what' you do nope feel that
pressure that you call the lock tell me
if it goes
off by what you do
no yeah it did do you feel that
friction it's off your joints are back
do you see that you you got to be able
to feel that okay do you see how it's on
look I'll show you you see see how I can
move her come
back as you feel that reconcile the the
pressure you feel it's off again there
stay there go back
reconcile it take the pain off is what
that means take the pain off you see
it's off safe stay stay there come
around watch your
joints do you see go back we're going to
go really slow as you take your kimy to
reconcile the
energy what am I doing keeping it on
keeping it on you see that's another
attempt to take it off go around again
you'll see It'll be off you see it's off
again go
back so as each reconcile that she does
I keep the joint
nonfunctioning as I go into the
technique it stays on on on again she's
trying to take it off faster you move
the faster I have to move okay I'm
keeping it on you see
that
on okay now I don't want to see I don't
want to go here that's not where it's
on okay I have to go into your Center
into your Center you feel that
difference and that's where my
projection
is okay try it
again all so now you're not in K DOA
you're in
Kona the concepts the principles are the
same but the prescriptions are not the
same okay
so as I go into his Center just like
kosa you feel it there it is he's going
to reconcile that energy and get back
into my Center okay and I'll show you he
because he can do a projection through
my Center you see you get it
okay this is where the nikel starts in
the guy being in my center and now like
you weren't supposed to do in KY DOA I
attempt to regain my Center you see that
so he he has it and I'm going to get it
back do you see that but before I
segment he keeps that same connection as
I am attempting to do that okay you see
so again project
me you see that so I'm taking you Kem
he's keeping that same feeling he'll
move wherever he needs to move to at any
point be able to project me
again Center I keep reconciling it to
free my
Center you see here I am okay now we're
down at the bottom and I'll show you I
have my Center which should mean I can
do what to him pro
project we'll get back there but I am UK
so I receive his projection again he's
not trying to just deal with my joints
he's got that same
feeling and now he projects my
center that is you can me
but that's also not it okay so he's not
just attacking my joints and I go
ah there's little counters that I'm
doing now to this point if I over
[Music]
counter then he would because of his
task just keep connection that much
faster do you get it that's what you
were doing so you you over countered too
quickly and you weren't ready for the
continuation why is it a problem let's
say I start to fall and I'm going that
way don't don't change this don't change
leave it in space where it is I'm I'm
going to fall this way do you
see looks like it
works but I'm going to do that slow and
you're going to see that he's going to
have to go over the top to keep the
center
and at this point as I start to fall I'm
now going against the lock as I put him
back into there you see that so I go and
now your net has a choice don't break
our
wrist you get it or break our wrist
okay so don't
fall instead just reconcile again you
see just
reconcile and he'll
continue
okay try it
again I don't why are you not
switching
okay so again you're in his joint if we
if we you're in her joint too so if we
watch how much of the move has started
there's no he's just standing there do
you see this is where the resistant
opponent punches you in the face okay so
you would go no no nothing in the
center nothing now here so the joints
work their way up till they affected his
posture as as a sense of something
different he'll he's going to grab right
and because you can project it any point
this means I'm in his center right I'm
not going to be in his arm not in his
arm the second of contact you come that
so I'm going to I'm going to move
through the architectural pattern of n
okay and I'll stop at various increments
in its spiral geometry and you'll see
that I can always project okay so I'm
going to start to
move there's that first part and again
in the center keep moving keep moving
and again there there it is right there
okay uh I'm going to go into the
technique here we are same thing
boom in the center I'm cutting through
the technique same thing in the center
same thing in the center and you have to
move so you can do it okay we're getting
into the technique same thing project in
the center
home in the
center always in the
center get to the bottom same
thing project even even without the
obvious
this movement of my hands that way is
still in his
Center okay and you can all
times reverse
[Music]
it okay which you cannot do when you're
only in the joints okay